just like a lot of people out here just
getting degrees by luck or by cheating
their way through if that was the case
in colleges so I accessible I just feel
like we'll have a lot of one of these
come a college grads on that side and my
dropouts on the other side first
statement I feared how I would be judged
if I didn't go to college just me man
that's cool it was the fear of me
King about what was thought as far as
like my peers but then when you start
bringing your parents into it and it's
like that's a greater fear but you live
for your parents it's like yeah you want
to make them proud so I just fear this
closure between me and my parents you
know yeah I am Sean Fitzpatrick
I went to Columbia Chicago for not even
a semester I was like no you know what
let's go back to California and undo
music I went because they wanted me to
go and then and then I said if you want
me to make you proud let me do this non
agrees come on in I wasn't afraid that I
would be judged if I didn't go to
college but I also didn't question going
to college it was just kind of the next
step and I didn't plan otherwise so that
path of growth seemed like it was the
next step yeah and you're encouraged by
your parents and they gave me that
pathway of saying you know the only way
you're going to succeed is through
college but then as I got older they
gave me the idea well you can do
whatever you want if you find your path
though you need to find your path but if
you can't you should go to college
I believe college should be free
I had an in-state like all of my tuition
was paid for and I still have dead now
I'm sitting on it and I don't have a job
it's not like a real job that the dad
definitely racks up it's ridiculous
that's true but that that becomes an
investment in the future so at the end
of the day so you have to take that on
education but does your like with a
degree you a higher paying job not in my
experience
I didn't even question going to college
until after I had finished it who's like
what do I do now and why did I even go
and you know if everyone went to college
it would become useless
just like a lot of people out here just
getting degrees by luck or getting
degrees by cheating their way through
and if that was the case in colleges so
I accessible I just feel like we'll have
a lot of wannabes and that people were
really passionate about you know what
they want to do or dedicating sweat
bones and tears into what they're doing
so the world would I don't think would
be a better place if everyone was just a
degree I changed my mind
yeah yeah I guess then you don't think
of it it's not college you're just doing
it just think about label workers like
people I just do manual labor you don't
need a degree to do some manual labor
work so if you have everyone you know
sticking their heads in a book we won't
have stuff being billed your house won't
be build your your cars won't be fixed
your all changed you know say like you
have to buy that in life especially in
the world it's a balance of 50 people
like I come from minority
underrepresented disenfranchised and in
my college experience I the higher I got
the less people that look like me that I
saw so the more people that look like me
in college would make me so happy that's
what I'm saying so like it's tremendous
to see more people going to college but
you have to realize that this is if you
get some I thought people don't want to
I just think that college education if
everyone had it I don't think would make
the degree itself useless oh no I'm I
think we were taking ID off a pedestal
not making it meaningless I know what I
want to do with my life
I'm still figuring it out but I'm in it
right now so I feel like I know but
there's so much more that's getting
revealed as I find out I'm currently
getting a degree in psychotherapy
however I still need two or three more
years to get on my hours and so I'm
debating whether or not even to get my
license and just be an a woman
empowerment coach and I'm gonna be done
with grad school I can fully invest my
all of myself into itself it took a
minute I mean yeah it was not an easy
journey and it was a lot of investing
and finding out that I was investing in
the wrong things so you know like I you
changed your market how to think about a
hot house like we really don't know I
want to say that I mean I don't feel
lost like I don't feel like I don't want
to do I don't know what I want to do
with my life I'm actively pursuing a lot
of goals right now and I don't
anticipate like one goal last me a
lifetime
exactly there goes like I know all the
things that I wants to do I'm just not
sure which one is the like for you guys
like this is it
for me I was like I'm Dibley dabble in
so many different things I'm just like
anything could be the final goal I just
don't know which one it is I wanna thank
you every crap I was going in school for
architecture okay and I was a three
years in and then I got into acting and
I bought the job and then I realized I
was like whoa I really like doing this
so dropped out of school and I decided
that I'd pursue acting instead when I
came later on after I did three years of
college I know and I did for three
classes before I graduated really I just
like I decided to leave because I felt
the time for me to pursue the things I
wanted to do my life was now and College
was holding me back from that education
is the key to success
so when I heard education and you know I
didn't necessarily associate it with
college yeah I just associated with
gathering all the tools and the data and
the knowledge and and then embodying
that into you but in whatever field you
want to be successful and beautifully
put and the success to doesn't just come
with look you know you have to you have
to work hard at what you want to do and
what success exactly so yeah I took
education has like a college degree when
you presented that question yeah yeah
that's why I didn't even walk out
because and you have to realize like we
learn daily like every day were learning
something and it's so funny but there's
no book in front of us to learn those
things that we learned it just so
happened that we cross the right person
or someone related that information to
us or you know just based off life
experiences so I don't think that you're
gonna be successful based on the fact
that you went to school or you know
you're opening up a book or something
you said alias with learning experience
every time you wake up in the morning
you should be learning something new at
the end of the day that's why I feel
about life so why shouldn't more so on
the same page
hey guys this is Dan and this is Jason
and you just watched another episode of
middle-ground thank you so much please
let us know in the comments below which
person's opinion resonated the most with
you we'd love to hear from you so anyway
you can get involved commenting liking
subscribing sharing with your friends we
really appreciate it it all helps see
you later